I remember when my old football coach used to sit us down after nearly every
practice and every weight lifting session with our lungs gasping for air and our
bodies just pushed past the point of what we thought we could do.
And he'd say,
we live in a microwave society.
When that is obsessed with getting instinct gratification,
it's a natural biological impulse for humans to want to minimize time and
effort.
We all have goals and dreams,
things we plan on accomplishing some day.
What we're really waiting for is a magic pill or someone to come along and do it
for us.
And the media we consume on a daily basis only makes this worse.
We think if we just look like the people in the magazine,
then everyone would finally accept us and we could be happy.
Or we think if we just won the lottery and never had to worry about money again,
then we can start enjoying our life and finally be happy.
But at the same time,
we don't want to put in the effort it would take to actually become the best
version of ourselves.
Why would I take the time and effort to learn about health and nutrition when I
can just eat fast food all day,
then take a fat burner to lose the weight,
wanting to get in shape with almost no effort.
Perfect.
Here's something called six minute abs where you get shredded and hardly have to
put in any work.
There's no such thing as something for nothing.
You can't cheat even if you wish to do so.
If you're like me and like most people,
what are the biggest things holding you back in life is that you're comfortable.
It just becomes so easy to get our basic needs of food,
water,
and shelter.
For us,
gone are the days of hunting,
gathering and getting what you need before you die.
And because of this,
it becomes very easy to fall into the pattern of comfortable mediocrity.
Sometimes it takes hitting rock bottom to actually start making meaningful
change in your life.
To quote Tyler Durden from fight club,
it's only when we've lost everything that we're free to do anything.
Okay?
Well you don't have to wait till you're sick,
homeless,
and depressed to make a change.
You can start by cultivating little habits of giving up instinct gratification
every day.
Start to its structure,
discomfort throughout your day.
Starting tomorrow.
Set your alarm 15 minutes earlier than normal and wake up immediately without
hitting snooze.
Your first instinct will always be to stay in bed and the more you give into
that instinct,
the more you damage your ability to use your willpower.
When everything in your body is telling you not to do something you said you
would do.
You have to tell yourself,
fuck how you feel and do it anyway.
This is the same feeling you will get anytime you step out of what is
comfortable for you,
no matter who you are,
you can generate five seconds of willpower and that is all that we'll take.
The hardest part about forcing yourself out of bed in the morning,
it's just the first five seconds and then after that it gets easy.
It's the same with anything that is outside of your routine.
The hardest part about starting to meditate,
go to the gym,
read and eat healthy everyday is just carving out the time to actually do it and
committing to do it
day.
Realize that whatever rationalizations and excuses you have for not doing it
today,
we'll be there every single day.
There will never be a perfect moment and you will never feel like it.
Anytime you try and break out of your comfort zone,
your brain will always come up with excuses to not do what you're trying to do.
Your brain doesn't care if you're living a fulfilled life or not.
All it cares about is self preservation and passing along its DNA and because of
this,
your brain will want to keep you where it's safe,
where it's comfortable and where there's no unknown because our brains evolved
to associate the unknown.
Yeah.
With danger.
Finding what scares you most and constantly exposing yourself to it can be one
of the most powerful things you do in your life.
Steven Pressfield wrote in his book the war of art,
that the more fear and resistance we have towards something,
the more certain we can be that we have to do it.
Our fear is like a compass that points true north to the one thing we should be
doing.
I spent most of my life suffering from pretty severe social anxiety.
I remember if I was eating lunch with a group of my friends and they started
hanging out with a group of other people that I wasn't comfortable with,
I would just go and wait in the bathroom until my next class started.
I was walking around constantly feeling like I was at the top of a roller
coaster just waiting for it to drop.
I thought everyone else experiences the world a certain way and that just wasn't
for me.
I thought this was how I was going to spend the rest of my life,
but it wasn't until I made the decision that it wasn't going to live like this
anymore,
that my life started to change.
I started to get in as many uncomfortable,
weird,
awkward situations as I could until I slowly started to learn to not give a
fuck.
I found what scared me.
Most of that,
I constantly expose myself to it.
This thing will be different for everybody.
For some people it will be giving a speech.
For others it will be approaching a beautiful girl and others that will be
starting their business idea or putting their art out for the world to see
humans evolve because we had a lot of evolutionary pressure put onto us.
He was get what you need or you're going to die and not pass on your genes.
Now that we've engineered a society where that's not the case,
we have to put that evolutionary pressure on ourselves.
It starts with every decision you make them.
The moment you wake up,
the habits you make,
the food you eat,
how you interact with people,
it's all either feeling an upward or a downward spiral.
So you start with one habit,
like waking up a little bit earlier every morning you feel less rushed,
so you actually start to practice meditation before you go to work.
Because of this,
your mind is more clear.
You're more mindful about the food you eat.
You start to eat clean.
You notice you have more energy throughout the day,
so you start to go to the gym every single day.
You're starting to feel healthier,
more energized,
and this makes you more positive with everybody you interact with,
your relationships with your friends and family start to improve.
You're happier and more confident and more willing to put yourself out there.
Maybe you decide to start that business idea you've always thought about doing.
Maybe you decide to ask out.
That cute girl you see every day on your way to work.
Small habits when done everyday can snowball and turn into big changes in your
life.
Don't focus on what you're doing instead focused on why you're doing it,
because the reason will always be more important than the temporary discomfort.